what's his name his name is Bruno La man
like that one better yeah well they
should get Bruno Lamar's because I think
he's really good at uh healing everybody
what do you think he would say to people
he would just say talk to the Moon you
know oh that's so true by all the things
he never had you know who do you think
that he would sit next to if he could
pick Oprah and the queen but Oprah a
little Winfrey
[Music]
all right
so you guys know who the president of
France is Joe take it away
close so accurate yeah so Pierre lapoo
no his name is is uh is macron oh yeah
macaroon it's not it's not Justin
Trudeau
that's the Canadian president but is it
Trudeau French it might as well because
he's a traitor thank you that was a
setup
I know so so he has overrided a
parliament uh Bill to to pass what they
call the retirement age bill right so he
has resorted to using special
Constitutional Powers there was what
they call a pensions overhaul in France
that was met with widespread protests
and Strikes all across France
and prime minister Elizabeth born
announced to the assembly that the
government would trigger article 49.3 of
the French Constitution
um and macron resorted to using special
Constitutional Powers to plan to raise
the retirement age to 64 from 62. yeah
for two years yep what's this well
people are living longer that's scary I
bet you France like burned to the ground
after that so yeah it's for people with
gaming headphones so they don't feel
ripped off French people started taking
the streets they were burning Furniture
in the streets I bet yep
um they would burn
if you tell a French man to work more
dude don't [__] start taking Muay
Thai so they could fight you it's like
what it is dude they just are burning
Furniture that's what they did like
imagine imagine the guys that are 62 who
just retired they're like yes yeah I
almost feel nice yeah so is it a bunch
of 61 year olds that are like [__]
[__] it's everybody so
um
so the plans were passed in Francis
Senate on two on Thursday morning but
had been due for a vote in the National
Assembly which is the lower house where
its approval was not granted so then
um prime minister Elizabeth Warren
announced the debt to the assembly that
the government would trigger article
49.3 which I mentioned before lawmakers
opposed to the reforms booed chanted
shouted resignation as she spoke and
then at one point the session was
suspended for two minutes as politicians
saying the national anthem too loudly
for her to even be heard that's the
filibuster right classic and then
mccrones Renaissance party argues reform
of the pension system is necessary
because they're [__] a little bit they
projected an annual deficit of 10
billion euros which is 10.73 billion
dollars each year between 2022 and 2032
so each year 10.73 billion dollars is
being sucked up into the pension fund
wow
um opinion poll suggests the majority of
the public supported industrial action
to oppose the changes which includes
requiring workers to contribute to the
system for 43 years to qualify for a
full pension strikes have now taken
place since the start of the year and
intensified and it's getting it's out
there like look at this [__]
oh my God it's a lot of furniture Santa
Monica yeah it's let me see that
literally just looks like here whoa
oh at night that shit's on fire but like
what did what did they throw like just
trash the streets are like packed with
all this kind of [__] yeah it's garbage
wow it's it's every all kinds of they
call it rubbish I guess over there what
when I was in uh when I was in Paris
they were dealing with um they were
doing like a like a massive Refugee
um situation yeah and I remember
thinking like dude this [__] looks like
you know how Skid Row is and it's pretty
packed imagine that times five yeah
exactly like tents were like [__] all
over it was crazy no that's it wasn't as
dirty but it was a lot of tense that's
happening in France too oh damn yeah so
so
um a lot of politicians right now are
trying to say hey we want to vote of no
confidence in the in the government
which would mean [__] you to to the
president
um Marine Le Prem you maybe have heard
of her before she's run against macron
in the past and lost
um she's basically saying like hey we
we're gonna do this so you know if you
don't like what's going on let's go
um and there's maybe you're not gonna be
a vote to dissolve the National Assembly
in whole new elections it's kind of up
in the air right now
um but there's a lot of unrest in France
right now
due to this I feel like France's friends
they protest so much that it makes the
protests in France makes makes it seem
like it's not that thing
they're always going on strike no no no
[__] though like every time they're like
flights from France are delayed because
the airport's on strike or like
something's on strike and I'm just like
damn they keep fighting dude
they just can't come to a conclusion
like are you trying to say like French
people are kind of soft or what no I
think they're lazy people is it
something is it something where the I'm
just kidding so we're going to wrestling
the legislature right the government
doesn't have the majority to approve of
something and the president goes well
[__] it we're doing it anyway that's
[__] up and that's kind of what's
Happening yeah kind of checking balances
of that I wonder why though I'm thinking
it's kind of like the US government and
warfare very laissez faire we don't pass
War resolutions anymore we just [__]
go yeah we're going off we're going off
of November 11th you just do whatever
you want because you know um we just did
an article about South Korea
raising the uh weekly hours right to
like 69 hours a week for full time right
so then
what if like this is a reaction to not
having enough people because that's an
issue that Europe America South Korea
Japan is facing is there's not enough
people not enough workers right now
we're going to see a huge Boomer
population just retire well you're
talking about yeah they're gonna retire
and there's not enough people down here
to pay for the people exactly so that
Gap is like what if they're doing this
move hoping to like
siphon it a little bit slower so now
instead of 60 uh what two you got 64.
maybe they know the math of like oh
there's a lot of [__] people at this
age so if we just pump it two more years
then we don't have all these people
retiring that's what the finance
minister of France says here he says
that the reform is just necessary to
ensure a fiscal balance by 2030. and he
says the government's made concessions
already including decreasing the
proposed retirement age from 65 to 64.
and he was confident they would get a
majority Department what's his name his
name is Bruno lemon like that one better
yeah well they should get Bruno Lamar's
because I think he's really good at uh
healing everybody what do you think he
would say to people he would just say
talk to the Moon you know oh that's so
true and he say like you know everyone
wishes that they were a billionaire so
[__] bad you know how about
billionaire so [__] bad
by all the things he never had you know
who do you think that he would sit next
to if he could pick
[Laughter]
I'm starting to remember
You Know It uh I I think my accent is
[__] though
that's pretty good yeah I mean like a
lot of people are I mean I'd be pissed
if I'm like what the [__] I was about to
retire or what does 64 turn into 66.
he's gonna keep going yeah well that's
what so that's what um a lot of the
workers who are likely to retire at 62
are manual workers and they're just like
yo I started work at a young age like
how the [__] do you expect me to keep
going easy for you to attack on two I've
just clocked in 40. yeah yeah right
they're not all social media managers no
it's like I'm missing an arm from the
[__] iron uh Factory that I've been
working at yeah yeah like I just took
the chair in the street that was on fire
last night
my back's thrown out okay that makes
yeah but but the the government's also
in a in a hole too because they're just
like yo there's all these people that's
gonna retire now we don't have enough
money for everybody what are we gonna do
and then they could they can try taxing
companies but it's actually the most
difficult to tax the the biggest
companies because they'll just run
they'll just go to other well they don't
want the companies to leave yeah like
they're like the they they're like a
country themselves not saying that it
can't be done but it's that's why a lot
of the times they [__] with middle class
and poor because like you know how like
they're going
um we're gonna check your memo we're
gonna do all that [__] is because we
don't have lawyers and and can't do
anything about it you can't do nothing
if Iris comes to us we're just paying
you're just paying yeah true but then
they go to Amazon or whatever and then
they're like oh this is gonna take like
15 years to fight these guys and get our
money yeah so it's just tough man I
don't I don't even know how they can do
it so a representative for the people of
who are going through this right they
say do you hear the people singing
singing the song
Stupid pull-ups
did he pull out the lyrics this [__]
he says it's the music of the people
yeah
it's the most famous it's the national
anthem it's what it's the national
anthem Joe's in the library reading a
bunch of other [__]
while we were watching Les Mis yeah holy
man yeah I skipped two four six seven
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign